so we've got um musicality what is
musicality as it relates to public
speaking well
it's similar to I mean the reason we use
the word musicality it's similar to in
music what makes it interesting is
partly the interpretation of the piece
right you play you play musical
instruments don't you yeah I double with
piano and guitar yeah and they have all
of these uh instructions about how loud
it should be and how quiet it should be
and how it should sound and it's the
same thing in speaking if you speak in
one emotion one energy level one tone we
call that monotone it's supposed to be
not a good thing and it can be like
being constantly excited and you you
know you have those people you meet who
are like always excitable or really
really quiet really really calm what
we're looking for with musicality is a
bit of contrast a little bit of movement
between the energies so that you can
express
yourself